see I have to travel through 40
different countries Abu Dhabi
I take 140 flight I have to travel for
366 days straight and all of that to
break the world record in bird-watching
I'm Erin Barse house I'm from the
Netherlands and I'm the world record
holder in bird watching a big year is
something pretty unknown in the normal
world but very used in the burning world
and it's basically you tried to see as
many species of birth in a single year
and that's exactly what I did in 2016
this whole adventure took a lot of
planning with a big year you of course
you have to travel by night to save
valuable daylight for burnings most days
of course start at 4:00 in the morning
when I arrived in some country in the
middle of nowhere
then intensive birding tried to see all
the species that I needed to see at the
service club and then bomb off to the
next location when I'm screwed I try to
sleep a little in the car or on the
plane but it was one continuous roller
coaster trip I had a lot of luck through
my big year but of course there were
also moments that I didn't see the bird
that I really hoped the seat somewhere
each disease pictures her hate my
overhang mix for instance the helmet
some dine Madagascar
was one of my childhood dreams to see
that birth and I walked behind a guy
with a machete for 10 hours straight
through the soaking wet jungle did t
kill America now I didn't have water so
as to lick water off of leaves to stay
hydrated and in the end it got dark and
I missed the birth and that's also the
beauty of burning you sometimes see the
birth you hope for you sometimes don't
see them in the end I set a new world
record somewhere in the second week of
November in Costa Rica the record
breaking where it was the buffy crown
roots are traced scoping through the
undergrowth at the move to Florida
reserves in the Costa Rica and in the
end I sold 6856 species that year so on
average about eighteen point eight new
species every day and that's about 65
percent of all the births we see in the
world people ask me why do you love
birds I asked them back you like being
outdoors you like hiking walking your
dog barbecuing I say imagine death
without the sounds of birds I think it
would be like eerie silence
nature would be different you know you
you would notice they're just simply the
most beautiful things there are in the
world
you
[Music]